[Aplausos]
han pasado cinco años desde que la
concejala negra Mariel y Franco fue
brutalmente asesinada aquí en Río de
Janeiro cinco años después sus
familiares y la sociedad civil se
preguntan Quién fue el mandante de este
asesinato y cuál fue la razón
[Música]
cada día que pasa nuestro dolor aumenta
no conseguimos hacer el luto este luto
del que precisamos después de cinco años
las autoridades de Río de Janeiro tienen
que dar estas respuestas no solo para mí
como madres sino también para los
electores de Mariel la familia y el
Brasil que clama por la justicia social
porque eso es lo que María
[Música]
yo conocí personalmente a Mariel hoy yo
siento que ella me representó de verdad
mucha gente que conozco la conocía la
amaban Yo hoy estoy aquí para apoyar
esta causa para saber Quién mató a
Mariel Franco
tras el cambio de gobierno la policía
pagará la abierta una nueva línea de
investigación recordamos que la hermana
de María Eli Daniel y Franco hoy es
ministra de Walter racial en el gobierno
Lula por esta razón la familia espera
ahora obtener respuestas sobre los
autores intelectuales de ese atentado y
también que por fin se celebre el juicio
contra los únicos dos arrestados
considerados los autores materiales del
asesinato